bang bang
what's up guys lunch money time
episode 100
with the beautiful and intelligent
polina marinova
pompliano we've got through a lot
during this pandemic we started this
show
we got married i probably annoyed the
hell out of polina she's still here
smart as ever entertaining as ever
while wall street's trying to get rich
the rest of us just trying to get our
lunch money right and hopefully that's
what this show's been doing for you
don't forget it's sponsored by block
five block five's got three products
buy and sell crypto on their crypto
exchange or you could deposit crypto and
get a us dollar loan
in against your collateral or you can
deposit crypto or stablecoin and earn up
to 8.6 percent apy
on an interest bearing account go check
out block five block five
dot com slash lunch money no brainer go
do it block five.com
lunch money hey girl what's up
i'm sad today why because we didn't do
anything for the people for the
hundredth episode
that's their fault i got something
coming but we're not going to do it
today for the 100th episode but we hit
100 episodes who do you have coming did
you ever think
planet thinks i don't plan anything it's
plain his birthday though
it's not my birthday august 27th is her
birthday
people don't realize i've been saying
the wrong birthday every day and now
people in the comments are like oh my
birthday's on the 21st too
august 24th is playing his birthday
today's 100 episodes what's going on in
the world
let's get into this um the fed faces a
major challenge in making its new
inflation strategy
official and apparently the u.s central
bank will be faced with a delicate
balancing act
if it opts to embrace a more relaxed
view on inflation
what are they saying is going to be the
new one oh wait they want to do more
than two percent inflation
they want to ramp up the inflation
target from the current two percent
where it has been for four years what
does this mean
you love inflation talking about no i
hate inflation i love talking about it
this is crazy talk two percent inflation
means that if we're hitting two percent
the bottom twenty percent of people are
experiencing anywhere between six to ten
percent inflation
every socioeconomic bucket
does not experience inflation the same
rich people actually benefit from
inflation
poor people end up actually getting hurt
by inflation so
wait what do you consider poor people
and rich people so if you basically
break
let's take the socioeconomic status of
people and you cut it into 20
uh kind of buckets so the top 20 of them
of americans
the top you know 20 to 40 percent
right the middle 20 and there's two
buckets at the bottom
the bottom 40 percent of americans get
crushed by inflation
45 of americans don't own any stocks 50
of americans can't come up with 400
emergency payment they live their life
paycheck to paycheck in all cash
and so if you're going to raise
inflation which these
geniuses want to do to try to get the
velocity of money going again
what you're going to do is you're just
going to continue to widen the
wealth inequality gap so the rich are
going to get richer and the poor are
going to get poorer
and when that occurs at one and a half 2
percent inflation if you then go above
two percent inflation
all you're doing is you're just making
it worse and so this idea of like oh
let's
solve the problem by driving more
inflation
i just don't agree with that's the
solution
someone told uh cnbc the alternative
strategy is to say well let's look over
a long-term horizon we've been missing
our inflation goal for a decade
so maybe we can run hot for a little
while the challenge with that is that it
can lead people to say the fed is not
serious about fighting inflation anymore
inflation is going to get out of control
yeah just so we're clear every every
single currency that's failed it's
because of hyperinflation
and so i think i'm not saying that
they're going to hyperinflate away the
currency but what i am saying is that
money is a belief system
and the second that people believe that
you're going to drive higher levels of
inflation they actually believe it
right what are they going to do they're
going to leave the dollar and go into
other assets
how far do you think we are from ever
becoming a zimbabwe
uh i don't know if it happens in
our lifetime okay so it's possible well
it's possible
oh it's definitely possible i mean look
here's a scenario right
what if all of a sudden they let
inflation start creeping up to
three percent four percent before they
actually start to do any sort of
quantitative tightening
they go to start doing quantitative
tightening and raising rates and all
this kind of stuff
and as they do that the market starts
gyrating and they realize wait a second
we can't do that
so we actually have to drop rates again
we have to print more money because
we're addicted to it now you're already
at
three percent inflation or whatever then
you just accelerate it and then what
happens when the official cpi numbers
get to
six seven eight percent the the bottom
twenty percent of americans would
literally be seeing twenty plus percent
inflation at that point like
what are you gonna do and so this is
just a really slippery slope
and this idea that like we're the
masters of the universe and we have full
control over the economy and we can
manipulate how we want
guess what doesn't have inflation what
bitcoin
facts well it's disinflationary that's a
whole nother thing we're not going to go
there ah let's not go there that was
good that was a good answer
so let's go what's next one in four
hotels
can't pay their mortgages the hotel
industry said it faces a default
disaster
in which 25 hotels are at risk of
foreclosure so there's there's this one
hotel
we've been talking to in new york and
first they were gonna reopen in
september now i got an email they're
like ah
no we're gonna reopen in october and
they keep pushing it
and they might not even open then so
what's gonna happen to all these hotels
i mean look this is what happens you
basically
are dependent on travel right like
that's how hotels work
and so you've got a mortgage and your
revenue is supposed to be
more than your mortgage payment and
that's and then you just make the
difference as cash flow and then you're
basically paying off the mortgage well
if your revenue goes to zero you can't
pay your mortgage like
surprised that it's only 25 of hotels uh
are currently being hurt
so in may um the world's largest hotel
chain marriott international said the
pandemic is having a more severe and
sustained financial impact on marriott's
marriott's business than 911 and the
2008 financial crisis combined
that's not surprising though really well
911 was a new york based thing but
that's also travel related yes but i
don't but it didn't affect it
yeah but i also don't think that there
was that like yes people were scared
but i don't think that it stopped people
from traveling
like everyone right there was some
percentage of people who stopped
traveling but it still didn't do that
the 2008 2009 crisis like people lost
their jobs whatever so again like there
was a dent in
travel but it's not like this i mean
like travel went to
zero right right there was hotels for a
prolonged period well there was hotels
who
literally closed their doors and said we
are not open
for weeks if not months at a time right
and so when you get in that scenario
like
you're just at zero revenue how do you
pay your mortgage you can't yeah
all right what's up with spacex spacex
has raised 1.9 billion dollars in new
funding
the company had been reported to be in
the funding process
earlier which pledged the post-money
valuation of spacex at 46 billion dollar
dollars following this raise it's kind
of low
well it's low what the valuation what is
the future value of
the business that ends up colonizing
mars right but like
you got to be a little little what if it
doesn't work
well of course but like that's the whole
idea of venture capital
right is you're basically looking at
like where can it go
yeah and he's already had a 46 billion
dollar evaluation like
what are the odds that spacex becomes a
trillion dollar company
my guess is pretty high actually right
now with their
new you know thing with the rocket and
the astronauts and nasa
people people are more well think about
it right like
they were the first company to do
reusable rockets they've secured a bunch
of these contracts like
they for sure have the mind share when
it comes to this stuff
and so i think that you're just looking
at a situation where it's a company
that's worth 46 billion dollars today
if they continue to execute right big if
they got to do the work they got to do
they got to get startling satellites up
they got to get all that stuff right you
know done
like well 46 billion is gonna be a blip
on the radar i think for where they end
up
right so let's not get ahead of the
horse and just
ride it out until it gets to a trillion
dollars
let's see what you can do elon fair all
right what's next
johnson and johnson will buy momenta
pharmaceuticals for 6.5 billion dollars
in cash
to bolster its portfolio of treatments
for autoimmune diseases
yeah like what you said yesterday
there's a boom if you're
creating a vaccine if you're creating
some sort of
medicine but these but these guys they
don't have anything to do with covid
right um i don't think so it's more
um it's more like autoimmune diseases
yeah i mean what's crazy is that uh the
shares are up 68
before the bell this morning and 68
is uh that brings it to just below the
offering price so uh johnson johnson's
gonna pay 52 dollars a share
and shares rose to 51.98 to talk about
market efficiency
uh but that's a 68 increase
yeah in from where it was trading issues
i think community and autoimmunity and
that kind of
those kind of like things
therapies are gonna um explode i think
that's my theory
yeah yeah i just like technology
technology driven science
in the sense of can you do things to
look with the human bolster the immune
system
well the body is a machine right your
brain is like software if you think
about it your body's a machine
just like we work on a car why can't we
work on a body yeah do all kinds of
things and use technology and stuff like
i think all that's going to happen
do you agree yeah i think johnson
johnson is really interesting they
acquired this
it was a robotics company that does
surgery
um very very precise surgery and they've
been
they've been crushing crushing it a
little bit by the way
who's whose tricep looks bigger right
here mine yeah you got a
big tricep there all right to get in the
gym all right go ahead sorry
[Laughter]
mit and boston dynamics team up on dr
spot a robot for remote covert 19
vital sign measurements so this is again
the robot with the little ipad on its
forehead
and what is it going to do
it's going to measure the technique so i
think it's going to take your like
vital signs so your temperature
so it's a it's the bosses dynamics
four-legged dog-like robot
we've talked about him use of
contactless vital sign monitoring
equipment
for taking measurements it's outfitted
with a tablet to make it possible for
doctors and nurses to have face-to-face
interviews with patients while they
conduct
exams the hyper-local version of
telemedicine has the potential to not
only reduce the risk of exposure for
medical personality it can measure
skin temperature respiratory rate heart
rate and blood oxygen saturation
all at once i love this dog uh it's fake
but i love it you also like the roomba i
know i've i've gotten really close with
the room but
i don't like that thing i and every time
he says something mean about it i get
mad
thing didn't do its job let's go can't
yell at it by the way the
robotics in medicine that's another
thing that'll be big
agreed robotic surgery robots who take
your vitals
yeah i like it all right what's up with
gpt3 okay
a college student used gpt3 to write
fake blog posts and ended up at the top
of hacker news what's the hacker news uh
hacker news is basically
um think of it as like a popular website
for nerds and if you get to the top
there's tons of traffic
uh and there's all sorts of people who
spend all day long trying to figure out
how to get to the top of
this ranked feed or not i guess yeah it
is ranked
feed so they get the traffic so this
college student liam poor was trying to
demonstrate that the content produced by
gpt3 could fool people
into believing it was actually written
by a human and
it was super easy actually which was the
scary part
i believe that robot could be a better
writer than some humans
well definitely that but also uh this
is a little misleading i don't say it's
misleading but like
so there's two components one is they
wrote a blog post that seems like a
human wrote it which is
you know they use gpt three it's
incredible uh
i absolutely think that if you have the
chance go and play with it and you'll
kind of yeah
you know what i couldn't do my my blog
post
okay uh but then the second page is
getting to the top of hacker news
uh you can kind of game it a little bit
in terms of like when you post getting a
bunch of people to go vote for it like
there's somebody number one yeah i mean
number one means that there was like
quality to it for sure
um and so i think that it's uh it's
pretty cool to see
this happening so he said that only one
person reached out to ask if the post
was ai generated although several
commenters did guess
gpt3 was the author huh i wonder if
we're going to live in a world where
you're like
did a human do that or was it a robot
are you kidding i already live in that
world
really yeah i never guess i see things
it's like basically saying is that
photoshop or is that a real photo
oh my guess right but i never i never
think about it i get memes sent to me
all the time and i gotta
figure out if they're real or not um you
know all right what's up what
what joke you got for us today oh man i
don't have a good one
uh oh what do you call a cat on the
rocks
meow one cool cat
wait i don't i don't get it on the rocks
yeah oh
on the rocks like on a drink come on
come on what do you call two birds in
love tweet hearts
[Music]
okay so what are your finger guns right
so what is one thing you've learned
from lunch money in the last 100
episodes
the best things in life are to do with
the people you spend the most time with
in love
okay ladies and gentlemen that was a
master class
um in suave
i know what you are doing you're fooling
no one
um what is mine you didn't even ask me
but i asked myself
mine is getting to know so many new
people
in the comments and showing off my
triceps all right
i just wanted to sit here and say nice
things about you've been a fantastic
co-host through 99 of the 100 episodes
that's right the first one she was over
here let me just say that
a hundred episodes of lunch money
coincides with a hundred thousand
subscribers on youtube
so that's like saying
uh and i have a hundred dollars in my
pocket so therefore those things are all
correlated no that's literally directly
correlated
we're gonna have a math teacher about
correlations if it was just you by
yourself do we think
what would what would be better is if
you said that it was causated
there's causation not correlation
there's causation and correlation
okay guys that's it for lunch monday
today we'll see you guys tomorrow
episode 100 for watching well while
she's trying to get rich for us let's
try to get our lunch money right
see you tomorrow i should have brought
my lunchbox today
bang bang hope you guys enjoyed this
episode of lunch money
as much as we did and don't forget lunch
money is now sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block flies my second favorite thing in
the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest-bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risk
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends
you